So nine years ago I quit my job as a
cryonics planner, you know for those people
who want to freeze themselves for a
thousand years, hoping to wake up in a
better world?
My job was to make sure their frozen
bodies would stay safe and sound for all
that long...
No pressure right? I mean how do you even
design a building to last for a
millennium? What if there's a zombie
apocalypse or a giant meteor? Or another
Global pandemic? How do you guarantee
your clients won't end up as popsicles
for some alien invaders?! Or in a zoo?!
I mean, given that nothing lasts forever,
what is a literally sustainable design?
Well good luck finding any answers on
the Internet.
Most of what you'll find a bunch of
greenwashing products or programs that
claim to be eco-friendly but they're
actually just as bad if not worse than
status quo. I mean they promise to have a
net zero impact but they don't tell you
how they measure that, or what they do
with the waste, or how they exploit the
workers, or how they brought the
politicians. I mean they don't care about
your future--they primarily care about
their profit.
What just about made me give up though was
when I was working on a huge map for San
Antonio. A map that showed all the
infrastructure--planned and the existing.
A map that revealed a shocking truth:
25% of the pipes underground were
old rotten. They're leaking, cracking
bursting, and contaminating the water supply.
They were violating the Clean Water Act
and the city was facing like a billion
dollar fine. How do you explain that to
the voters? How do you tell them they
have to fork-over over billions of dollars
for something they never asked for, never see
never care about? How do you tell them
they have to pay for flushing toilets?
You know, so that's the burning question:
how do we create a truly sustainable
human world? You know, world where we don't ruin
everything for ourselves and our kids?
A world where we don't have to worry about
climate change, pollution, resource depletion, or extinction?
A world where we can have a harmonious
story between us of nature?
After a year I was so stressed out by
this question and I decided to seek some
spiritual guidance. I ended up cooking
breakfast for this Tibetan monk. He was
very nice, very wise, very... bald.
But over some scrambled eggs and coffee,
he asked me what was bothering, me what
did I want to learn? I babbled on about
my interest in impermanence, fractal
geometry, psychology, storytelling... And he
stopped, and he said "Storytelling...
that's it! that research needs to be done!"
So I did. I quit my job, packed my
cats and I moved to Cyprus. Here I read a
lot of books and articles--and I came
across this amazing story about two
Australian researchers who were
following a "songline". Now, a "songline"
it turns out it's like an epic GPS the
aboriginal people used to navigate the
land. They sing the stories, and if
they're going in the right direction, the
landforms along the way correspond to
the characters in the story.
Okay so the year is 2014, and these
researchers are walking along, singing
their little hearts out when suddenly
they're standing in the sea. They thought
they messed up somehow. Maybe they took a
wrong turn at the burning bush?
But then they realized: maybe this song
continues under the water?
And sure enough they found the rest of
the landmarks submerged in the sea on
oceanic charts! This song line was so old
it dated back to the last-ice age, when
the sea level was that much lower.
This song line had survived for like 10 thousand
500 years--passed down by word of mouth for
at least 500 Generations!
Now, that's longer than any cyronics
project ever dreamed of! And probably more
fun...
Well, this blew my mind: how can we use
this ancient technology to shape our
future? Maybe we could leverage
continuity going backwards...to go
forwards. But how can we tell our stories
to the land like that and make them
stick?
Well, it turns out it's just that simple:
you need to map your stories. You know
the stories you tell yourself, or your
friends, or your therapists: meaningful
stories. The stories that make up who you
are and where you come from. All those
stories have a setting--and a setting
can be mapped!
Imagine our stories like a tapestry and
when we lay them out on the land we
could see how the threads of each other's
stories intertwine and how they tug at
each other, how they harmonize.  Now with
this knowledge, we can spin new tales
that build upon the old--you know like
weaving new threads to fill in the worn
holes of that tapestry.
And mapping our stories isn't just for
personal insight. We could use them to
guide decisions about our neighborhoods:
climate, immigration, business, development,
isolation. We can make sure that
everything we do is in harmony with our
stories--or at least not
contradicting them.
Just to live together we need to
know where each other are coming from!
The aboriginal people of Australia
showed me that the stories, mixed with
the land, can last for thousands of years.
So using stories of the people here
in Famagusta, I made a prototype of a map
of stories we and
our descendants could adapt and evolve.
Stories that could last for ten thousand
years or more.
Now, we all know there are gaps in the
structures that support our society. In
order to enable communities to plug
those gaps, we need to build a narrative infrastructure now.
One that maps stories
and communities across the world.
With narrative tools and GIS, we can create a
"narrative infrastructure" for the future.
A future that's not on ice, but alive
with stories.
Thank you very much.